♪ [intro music] ♪
Give me one minute, and I'll show you
how Cloud Monitoring
can help you monitor, troubleshoot,
and improve your infrastructure
and applications performance.
Cloud Monitoring is a critical component
of Google Cloud's observability offerings
and provides visibility
across your apps and infrastructure,
regardless of whether your app is running
in Google Cloud, On-Premises,
or in other clouds.
It automatically captures metrics
and allows you to define custom metrics
unique to your application
and business use cases.
Using the Metrics Explorer
and Monitoring Query Language,
you can analyze these metrics on the fly,
identifying correlations,
and easily add the corresponding charts
to a dashboard.
Cloud Monitoring provides
a consolidated view
of the health and performance
of your apps and infrastructure,
making it easy to spot anomalies
using Google's data visualization tools,
out-of-the-box dashboards,
where you can easily create
your own custom dashboards.
But we know you can't sit around
all day looking at dashboards,
so Cloud Monitoring provides alerting
where you can create policies
to alert on performance metrics,
uptime, and service level objectives.
Using Cloud Monitoring is simple,
you can access it
on the Google Cloud Console
or using the APIs.
If you're using GKE,
Monitoring is enabled
by default for your clusters.
For VM, simply install
our agent to get started.
For all GCP services,
Cloud Monitoring is pre-configured
to automatically collect metrics.
It is free to monitor all your GCP metrics
and comes with a very generous
free tier for custom metrics.
This makes it easier to get started
and affordable pricing thereafter.
So next time you're looking to monitor
your applications and services,
take a minute to look at Cloud Monitoring.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/monitoring.
♪ [outro music] ♪